short avec ma meilleure amie les
pêcheries du coup les dizaines de mecs
qui l'ont interpellé est d'abord ils ont
interpellé d'abord et louis ducreux ne
s'est pas retourné moi je sortais juste
et m'ont tout de suite dit qu'il était
un [ __ ] 1 ghz ou est-ce que tu peux parler
un petit peu plus fort yanis parce que
comme tel match c'est vrai qu'on
n'entend pas très bien merci ils m'ont
d'abord en soute et 2 pd2 gay g après
j'ai pris le bras de ma meilleure amie
on est avancé ils m'ont d'avoir attrapé
par derrière ils m'ont jeté du mont fera
t g combat mais rania s'interpose et âme
à relever on a avancé notre chemin il
alors là c'était le gramme ils s'étaient
venus des deux côtés du bâtiment ils
m'ont alors primes ont connu matin
contre le grillage m'ont jeté par terre
ou en frapper deux coup de prendre des
shoots dans la tête c'était vraiment
horrible
et de 5 gratuit franchement c'était
gratuit et voilà d'autant plus chez le
palier pourquoi toi ils ont commencé à
insulter en fait comme ça oui ben oui et
tu les connais c'est non pas du tout non
pas du tout il te reprocher quoi ben mon
vieux s'insulter de [ __ ] et de gays et
après m'ont frappé
et voilà
alors mais en plus tu n'as pas répondu
non et donc ils continuent attraper ces
cinq films et ça rigolait
alors ils se sont acharnés sur toi une
première fois comme tu as dit sont
revenus ensuite et après ils ont
commencé à filmer
qu'est ce que tu t'es dit à ce moment là
que j'avais mon rêve
très clairement
je pouvais rien faire j'ai pu partir
crier il ya une maman qu'est venu sauver
que je remercie beaucoup mais sûrement à
vous et je ris je la connais vraiment
pas mais voilà
ce kit ont parlé après l'agression
ah oui c'était bien marché par marché
pendant
pds qui m'ont déjà très j'ai pris fuite
et je suis rentré chez ma mère j'ai rien
dire à personne mais j'avais pleuré on
n'a rien dit à personne non j'attends
n'a pas parlé tous non ces deux
commissariats cavac ma mère pour dire
qu'il fallait qu'il joue mais parce que
s'il répète cette vidéo mais un rappel
tout sera ensuite j'aurai réagi
david et douleur quand même j'avais vu
que j'avais des marques mais chez moi
j'avais vu quand soigner du coup voilà
tu comptais rien dire exactement
pourquoi tu me dis rien dire fort des
représailles quand conviennent jeu c'est
pas con c'est la honte ans je me fais
frapper finaux mais non j'ai pas de
larmes amères bon moment je me suis fait
frapper mes films mais aussi pour moi je
pouvais rien je pouvais rien faire en
flip
avait peur
tu as dit séquelles physiques encore ah
non non ça va mieux mais ça y est tu as
vraiment cru que tu allais d'aller
mourir oui exactement
tu arrives à à dormir en ce moment à
hama ans en fait
j'adore vraiment très peu moi je
n'aurais vraiment très peu
je n'arrive pas à m'en remettre au fait
et j'ai du mal à être moins cher
renfermé sur moi-même toutes mes
journées b challenge et je sors plus de
chez moi je
suis finir en fuite je n'en ai pas fini
mais non tu es tout jeune le magnifique
je devais tout à l'heure n'était pas
finie du tout mais c'est pour moi ma vie
à définir ont fait tu passes devant nous
dans la une tous les journaux non non
non j'aime reconnaissance ma soeur m'a
proposé pas vous c'est pas vous dire moi
les gens c'est pas bon
c'est pas besoin la honte c'est ce qui
vous ont agressé je n'avais pas avoir
honte jamais jamais celui de ceux qui ce
soir doivent avoir honte c'est ce qui
vous hante à grèce mais comprenez-moi et
que regarder on vous filmant vous frappe
en jeu s'est pas fait
moi j'ai honte je sens que les chefs
vont me regarder - diarra c'est lui on
va me prendre pour moi c'est comme ça
même étiquette je peux pas ce qu'on va
d'abord voir si tu peux me permettre
monsieur va d'abord voir que vous êtes
une victime vous êtes une triste victime
et que va d'abord voir des sauvages qui
agresse un homme innocent et
profondément bon et sur les étés
consciencieuse et ça c'est inadmissible
hésiter mon organisme a évité une
dizaine au taux d'obésité peu et du coup
quand j'ai avancé bien elles sont vos
chemins savenay des deux côtés de
l'allée où là où j'allais et c'était
fini
l'imprimante et on m'a cogné contre lui
contre le grillage
jeté par terre je criais arrêté et je
criais je pouvais moi j'avais aucune
défense va pas crier tout ce que je
pouvais faire
yanni nous avait contacté aussi avec
avec ta soeur un grand merci à malte est
là pour rétablir aussi la vérité par
rapport à ce que ninon à dire sur notre
plateau
pourquoi vous étiez un petit peu échaudé
par ce qu'il arrive parce que c'est faux
c'est faux parce qu'ils étaient
accompagnés de deux personnes alors que
c'est faux réplique avec une seule
famille ces jours là y'avait pas et des
jeux de regards avec ces jeunes
comment il la montre je suis vraiment on
l'a peut-être raconter une mauvaise
version puisqu'il est venu après n'était
pas sur les lieux et ne fait pas de sens
mais votre version que c'est forcément à
l'abri puisque vous vous y étiez donc
que voilà et puis vous êtes la victime
donc voulu vraiment s'il vous ont tapé
c'est ça qui est fou
comme ça gratuitement gratuitement
certains insultant le pbd après une fois
une femme à avoir ou d'art frappé ils
m'ont demandé d'où je venais et c'était
une agression homophobe ah oui car
évidemment après moins de deux venaient
bien marcher patron 20 pb
après il faut avoir couru mais m'ont
coursé mais je savais le trou d'un trop
trop peur du coup j'ai vraiment pris
chérèque
est-ce que tu estimes
que c'est devenu un danger pour toi de
habiter où tu habites actuellement avec
louis
prix car tu as peur je rentre third
watch et non en fait c'est la seule fois
où là où je sors pour vénérer fille et
moi je reste chez moi enfermé même pour
à la boîte honnête je descends même pas
je fais rien du tout mais j'en ai je
suis chez moi je regarde les gens parler
moi la télé ou quotidien un matin je me
lève le matin et je serai je me couche
je stresse je fais rien du tout d'autres
alors ça serait est venu avec toi même
merci d'être là mercer mme
hamel quand tu vois ton frère comme ça
je sais que toi tu as une rage en toi
incroyable
qu'est ce que tu essaies de faire pour
qu'il aille mieux et qu'est ce que tu as
envie de nous dire ça parce que je sais
que tu étais très en colère mais en fait
moi ce que ce que j'ai en moi la rage
c'est que comment est la banaliser la
chose il ya non
c'est pas les gens comme toi tu me
connais pas c'est pas parce que là ça
passe en demie de marche et vous et ses
manières de faire sadia gagne on n'a pas
à rentrer là tu vas chez ce qu'il veux
pas insulter des gens comme ça pour lui
sur un vcd petit je ne sais pas quoi ils
l'ont insulté et il l'a regardé non ici
ils étaient plusieurs cures évadé d
chercher du regard ici par dérive à
avoir des conséquences ici c'est ça et
de voir son sens sont sans sa famille
son petit frère comme ça partout dans
les vidéos se faire frapper comme ça
mais un put on a mal aux machines perte
de deux familles s'ils demandent mes
enfants plus tard il vous sort frappe
est comme ça et on reste comme ça en
fait un puissant juste garde
tes parents ils ont dit quoi choquer
bien sûr ils ont peur pour toi bah en
fait qu'ils ont pas plus que peur en
lisant
j'ai l'impression que c'est eux qui est
qui ont vécu la chose le matin c'est
normal 6h01 ils sont je sais pas comment
quand vous dire face armé
entre enfants avaient une soutiennent
ils soutiennent vraiment chez lui je le
remercie
mais même en fait j'ai l'impression que
eelv était avec moi ces jours là j'ai
l'impression
alors vous avez confié que ce n'était
pas la première fois vous subissiez
jurant de violence depuis le collège
vous subissez des faits de harcèlement
et de violence qu'est ce qui s'est passé
depuis quand vous faites agresser un
document ccm là tu as dix sept ans vous
ce temps en tentant quelques là ça y est
déjà rigide est ce que l'arrivée
d'accord ça ça a joué ça dans le fait
que tu te sois déscolarisés tu n'es plus
aller à l'école
qu'est ce qui se passe et 10 mois
l'école ben je me faisait harceler
des fois sexuellement
des fois
sexuellement c'est à dire pas de par
d'autres oui il faut que les élèves du
collège auquel cas son sixième ça c'est
l'axé première fois d'abus sexuels moi
ça se passe en sixième ce qui s'est
passé il ya un jeune homme qui venait
derrière devant tout le monde en tout la
cour mcdc pantalon chez que tout nu
droit tout le monde j'ai tout type
comme ça fait sous le choc et non parce
que plein la personne n'a pas été viré
de l'établissement
et voilà ça c'est la première agression
c'est ça ensuite ça s'est passé il faut
que tu as été séquestrée dans ton
collège c'est ça non ça c'était dans mon
lit c'était 30 au lycée qu'est ce qui
s'est passé ce jour là
surtout la cantine parler me laver les
mains d'accord j'ai déjà mon essai sans
cynisme on voulait le trap et du coup
moi j'ai couru je me suis caché dans les
toilettes ils sont donc venus avec des
tournevis ont frappé du tournevis ils
ont ouvert la porte et le tour nos vies
ils nous frappaient je devais finir à 17
heures ce jour-là j sortir à 14 heures
gg je me sens fils gdc j'ai sorti tout
c'est un des porte plainte au
commissariat de montgeron d'ailleurs
qu'est ce qui est des professeurs et on
dit quoi
opérer un rien oui ce que tu as porté
plainte qu'en année pour son vétéran de
la plainte je vais porter plainte car
tournée dans six séries sur tourner deux
ou trois mois après
et après j'ai appris en un jour mais
plus tard ils m'ont dit que je devais
redoublé parce que j'avais trop
d'absences et du coup j'ai dit excusez
moi mais moi je reviens plus ici je suis
désolé en voir leur jeu mais quand vous
portez plainte vous y allez avec vos
parents ou à une enquête fait sa fête
s'est classée sans suite d'accord voilà
enfin attendent de speed pourtant j'ai
des prénoms on a tout mais on m'a jamais
rappelée pour mieux réussir ici
hamel en fait tous cet acharnement faut
partir du point de départ et alice il
était beaucoup sur les réseaux sociaux
d'accord il faisait beaucoup de vidéos
de snapshot où il faisait des playbacks
où ils dansaient au gré des des petites
manies du coup les gens se sont déjà il
est gay et à l'armée calibre incident
voilà le suisse est parti de salé à 13
fois tous les jours tous les jours que
jalousie des insultes des menaces à
regarde ton frère y fait quoi ah mais
vous n'avez pas honte et où c'est dur
pour nous on est sa famille c'est pas
comme si on était des des inconnus ou le
voisin quand ça nous touche nous
personnellement ça fait mal ça fait très
très mal c'est pour ça que tout cet
acharnement de base elle a commencé
parce qu'ils s'amusaient sur les réseaux
sociaux etc delà de bouche à oreille des
premières vidéos il se faisait agresser
danse dans notre quartier ses frappes
aussi du coup ma mère pour le protéger
elles sortent du quartier c'était encore
pire c'est c'était vraiment pire et eux
ils ont dû le reconnaître par rapport à
ses anciennes vidéos qui faisait sur
snap et tout parce que pour dire ah le
guet le pb est tout
on peut pas qu'est ce qui paraît alors
comme tu vas y y il ya eu plusieurs
agressions dans le cadre scolaire
personne n'a agi parce personne on t'a
laissé en détresse enfin
qu'est ce qui s'est passé avec une
altercation avec tout prof en quatrième
égalant sa
quatrième les ingés transport dans la
1ère j il ya une jeune fille ham avait
baissé mon pantalon
je saurai vous ici
et je suis parti dans le projet d alma
baissé mon pantalon
imaging quoi elle a baissé son pantalon
eddie mercier jean louis diarra baisse
mon pantalon ne comprenait pas dans quoi
elle baisse mon pantalon et il m'a dit
un jour tu m'as dit vaches et là c'est
que je parte ça c'est que je l'expliqué
du coup plus tard c'est moi qui a été
viré pour ce collège puisque j'ai mal
parlé à mon professeur
en sachant qu'il savait très bien que je
suis blessé de l'harcèlement ma nation
je sais pas je trouve ça vraiment lâche
que virer une victime
tout ça parce que je me suis navré je
suis humain comme nous tous ici ce soir
chacun a ses faiblesses jacasser pro for
nature moi j'étais seul je savais pas
comment réagir et du coup je vais dire
au professeur tu viens d'en faire depuis
depuis la classe de 6e c ça en fait
c'est à dire quand tu sors dans la rue
même dans ton quartier toujours oui je
serai toujours frappé une nuit enfin
quand je sors mais maintenant surtout
non mais je marche avec loana la
correction l'agression tu savais fin tu
savais pas mais tu te disais ça va
arriver un jour aussi une agression
aussi violente puisque je me fais
toujours agressif il a pas que tu vivais
là tu vis la peur au fond c'est ça la
peur au jour le jour je marche avec ma
mère un jour à cma ça je me suis fait
insulter de bd devant ma mère
devant une barre de famille
il ya un discours maintes fois tu as
porté plainte
plus eu une dizaine de fois une dizaine
de fois et jeanne ont marre à plus
haut risque et non dans cette histoire
est bon d'un côté c'est que grâce on va
dire à cette vidéo mais sain et à bouger
oui c'est ce alors que alors s'il verte
la strophe s'est passé ça mais je me
demande il ya une seigneurie mais c'est
ça c'est qu'ils arrivent à un drame
pareil c'est ça bouge derrière oui parce
que je vous dis il ya eu pire que ça il
y avait plusieurs vidéos avant celle-ci
savoir plus rien plus pire que cette
histoire la pire que ça pierre que ça
pire que ça les agressions pire que ça
soit yanis a agréé sont même
sexuellement pire que celle là ma mère
et mon petit frère son parti porter
plainte et à rien qu'à bouger même à
l'heure d'aujourd'hui la plainte on sait
pas où elle est la ferme en sais pas
depuis que cette vidéo est sortie dans
tous les médias là ça fait que d'appeler
ma mère et savent et sa bouche de man
yanis il a rendez vous avec un avec une
6 4 justement par rapport à cette vidéo
alors que compte porter plainte par
rapport aux autres agressions qu'il a
subi on n'avait aucune aucune nobel aux
tubes en inox
ganis et fourre tout à l'heure tu disais
que ta vie et tai chi minh et foot us je
ne peux pas entendre ça d'un garçon
comme toi qui a tout pour parce que
steam je voyais tout à l'heure d'un très
beau garçon tu t'exprimes très bien la
17e à la vie devant toi on peut pas
entendre ça comprenez moi que de se
faire frapper tout le temps c'est
parfait mais tout le temps est plus une
vie je passe devant la télé ou quotidien
fait mais tu peux être nommé c'est pas
fini du tout bougé contraire on va on va
essayer de tenir là comme m'a dit ta
soeur ce g
peut-être va faire bouger les choses
qu'est-ce qui aujourd'hui on se dit
qu'est ce qu'est ce qui se passe je
crois que si je peux me permettre c'est
inacceptable que les plaintes ont été
classées et moi je peux vous aider là
dessus dire que moi je peux vraiment
vous aider cher que ça valait réactivée
on va leur arriver et je m'engage
gratuitement elle est réactivé cette
note est à saisir un juge d'instruction
parce que ce qui se passe est
inadmissible c'est scandaleux c'est
inadmissible et ça ne doit pas ça ne
doit pas ça ne doit pas vous ne devez
pas enfin pas pardon de le dire comme ça
mais c'est terrible ce qui vous arrive
j'avoue êtes enfin pardon et ses essais
vous êtes la victime bien sûr il c'est
inacceptable vous dites que vous avez
honte c'est impossible enix ne pas avoir
dressé sert à rien fait de mal mais je
vais marcher dans la rue le g20 ou deux
mais
il a dû tout venant 6e d'avoir honte
d'être attaqués à plusieurs et la chose
qui fait ou mal aussi en tant que que
soeur ces deux d'entendre tout le temps
tir à il est gay à y réfléchir aux idées
il est comme ça
pourquoi parce qu'il s'habille jeans
serrés il a des manières efféminées
c'est
soit qu'ils ne soient pas peut encore
restants c'est pas une insulte c'est mon
est homosexuel on est hétérosexuel on
est bisexuelle et et puis cela n'est pas
une raison ça n'est pas une insulte
c'est surtout moi pardon mais ne faites
pas le jeu de vous justifier bien sûr
c'est à dire que ce qui ce qui s'est
passé que vous soyez gay ou pas c est
uniquement vous que ça concerne en aucun
cas ça ne peut justifier excuser ou quoi
que ce soit jamais jamais vous êtes
exactement comme vous êtes et vous avez
absolument pas vous justifiez de quoi
que ce soit est ce que vous êtes c'est
une victime yanis aujourd'hui
qu'est ce t'en vie de lancé comme appel
vraiment tu as besoin d aide qu'est ce
que tu aimes à avoir comme j'aimerais
vraiment
vous partir avec ma famille me laissait
tranquille un peu plus que les mêmes
chez ma mère pour avoir une interview il
croft que pharma journalistes et jean
michon bat chez toi tout un tas tout est
mais vert fois les inquiète après bfm tv
mais quand j'étais parti trouvera une
gestion à peine une heure ma mère reçoit
plein de coups de fil est ce que moi
j'ai peu dur à l'enquêtrice les médias
du tout au courant et qu'on les
accueille nîmes n'ont pas réagi
je trouve ça vraiment lâche dans le
cadre est sympa l'adresse mais le
quartier où ma mère l'a dhabi c'était du
vent c'est quelqu'un hadji à 102
yanis pourquoi tu es venu ce soit dans
cette émission
et pourquoi tu es venu exprimer à la
télé avec ta cela parce que c'est trop
fort trop pris de l'ampleur
stop mouassa introduire stop stop à tout
ça en fait t'as envie contre laisse
tranquille c'est sale ça m'aurait bien
vivre un peu ta des rêves encore vu non
le site à plus de 7 ans je n'ai jamais
eu un si tu fais des vidéos qui marchait
bien qu'ils avaient envie de
c'était pas un rêve car loisirs non mais
tu t'éclates et à faire ça on critiquer
derrière
rien les réseaux sociaux c'est ça qui a
démarré aussi le drame qui s'ajoute au
hsv real man
familles
mangeant coup
te dise quoi tes amis ma meilleure amie
instruction soutien bien sûr s'inquiète
avec toi comment ça qui est avec toi
communication et d'autres filles elle
est traumatisée forcément elle aussi
elle est choquée mais ces gens et mais
on les a retrouvés du passé ça mais en
fait
il n'enquête par rapport à ces jeunes là
et basson les dix on a trois qui ont été
retrouvés d'accord et je couds balle à
la faire aller en cours
il ya dix questions envie de dire à tes
agresseurs ce soit
vraiment
des chiens sont inquiets plusieurs mois
jamais quelqu'un qui a les crocs mais
cela seul face à moi
j'ai jamais vu quelqu'un
pour moi je trouve ça un lâcher de venir
à plusieurs sur leur personne
ça en fait
le/la comment ça a été fait c'est un
effet de groupe bien sûr c'est un effet
de groupe
c'est tout comme ça c'est ils se sentent
forts à à plusieurs ça a toujours été
comme ça ameute amélie qui stocke
question envie de dire tout ce qui a un
qui agresse ton frère qu'est ce que tu
leur dirai ce que je sais que tu es
extrêmement inari qu'est ce qu'il leur
dirait pour qu'ils arrêtent pour qui le
laisse tranquille il les connaît même
pas il les connaît pas du tout encore il
aurait fait quelque chose à quelqu'un de
leur famille ou leurs amis il les
connaît pas du tout qui le laisse
tranquille si il veut marcher dans la
rue et qu'il a ses manières 2 et c'est
ce qu'il veut il fait ce qu'il veut
qu'ils le laissent tranquille mais en
tout cas j'espère juste que cette
histoire elle va pas se terminer comme
ça c'est tout je sais ce qu'ils ont fait
c'est vraiment lâche de là mais ça
aurait pu être beaucoup plus grave mais
là ils sortent le dramatique il faut un
lieu sûr et il faut il faut arrêter de
penser que dans leur petit est là il ya
des familles derrière s'ils n'auraient
arrivé quelque chose à mon petit frère
nous notre ami c'est elle en prend un
coup derrière il faut j'ai déjà en
paroisse qui est malade
thomas merzouki qui paierait les tours
et auxquels je t'aime comme les choses
c'est dur pour nous donne que cette
instance en tout cas où c'est le dernier
de la famille et 2 et 2,2 tout prendre
soit c'est un jour vraiment je crois
vraiment jo il faut que votre statut de
victimes soient reconnues c'est très
important vous avez combien de frères et
soeurs savent combien ma famille on est
5 5 donc il ya nice c'était le petit
dernier bébé le permet tad état d grand
frère tu as dit qu'est ce qui te dit tu
es bon friends
ben ils me soutiennent
et sont énervés surtout contre eux
contre ces jeunes là parce que hier le
jeune minot report de montgeron tu
parles de ton quartier je parle du
junior ton quartier fait pas le poids ne
parle pas d'histoire de quartier tu me
parles de ton village c'est pas ça le
truc on ne banalise pas la chose et là
qu'on met en fait comment il a parlé
hier hélas trop banalisé la chose c'est
pas comme ça même si c'est des petits
comme dit déjà dans la sphère il ya un
jeune de 17 ans dont 6 et pour lui il
appelle ça un petit
il a rien dans le cerveau du aussi et de
et de dire mais c'est pas grave c'est
des petits de toute façon il n'ya pas
faire ça comment ils ont en fait c'est
entendre les cris de mon petit frère
dans les vidéos sama asama plusieurs
jets ça ça prend aux tripes et
2,2 de rester comme ça sans sans rien
faire vraiment c'est ça le plus dur en
fait de danse et on essaie de l'aider de
le soutenir mais juste avec nos paroles
je crois je sais qu'il ya des c il lui
manque encore quelque chose et tout ça
veut dire que tout le temps il va rester
enfermé à la maison et là que 17 ans il
ya des choses à vivre même si je sais
pas fatah vous avec tes amis et où il
veut pas parce qu'il a peur de sortir et
va dire on va me frapper c'est pas ça il
avait 17 ans aujourd'hui moi j'aimerais
que tu tues reprenait espoir
turbine normalement
il faut que tu reprennes et sport rien
dit
moi je te propose un truc
je sais que tu aime bien faire des
vidéos c'est est ce que tu veux venir un
petit peu
faire un stage auprès de nous dans
l'équipe de production
voilà c'est vrai que changer les idées
tu vas voir autre chose
quand tu voudras je te laisse le temps
de réfléchir
je pense qu'il faut que tu ailles de la
banque qui sortent de ce qui est sûr
en tout cas nous on souhaite beaucoup de
bonheur yanis on sera là pour toi du
coup
on va t'aider
ce drame est ce que c'est un drame c'est
peut-être le tournant tu t'habilles
aussi et ce peut-être que ce drame pas
faire réagir
et j'en ai peut-être que ça va faire que
ta vie va s'améliorer aussi à partir de
maintenant bizarrement et c'est ce qu'on
va essayer de faire
rejouer mais bon
faut réagir et faire réagir la justice
aussi parce qu'on pourra pas si bien sûr
vous rapporte d'assurer exactement
permis même pire moment donné moi je
rate dans ces cas-ci ni sur les
divisions sont issus maintenance et les
fabriquera sauf chez lui ou partir et
partir avec toute sa famille c'est pas
ça l'histoire il doit pas partir les
marqueurs pour agresser à 10 c'est pas
des bonhommes t'agresse pas un mec comme
ça a dit s'en tape terrain la nature
ouais même arnaque dit me disent qu'ils
ont ça me sidère
pardonnable maintenant je veux siffler
je dis ça fasse les choses celui qui
implique à taper la porte sur la sur la
maîtresse lakamy la maîtresse bercy en
cinq mois avec sursis merci moment donné
ça bouge yanis et amel pour avon merci
d'avoir été là ce que vous avez un
dernier mot à dire même merci beaucoup
pour tout ce que tu fais pour moi parce
que d'avoir accueilli moi et ma soeur
c'est beaucoup trop version marque
beaucoup maintenant on va essayer de t&d
quotidien
amen
tenais à vous remercier déjà
et que j'espère que la justice sera
faite hecker on va vous aider la tuque 2
s'élève à vraiment bougé on va vous
aider là dessus c'est bien qui est qui
va être division ce soit on va vous
aider il vaut justice et yanni je te le
dis si tu as envie d'être un petit peu
avec moi vous changer les idées et venir
nous rejoindre tu es le bienvenu parce
beaucoup